find addison it's a new company but with
a very long heritage it was a tough
project to me because everything was
small less 100 percent designed what if
God is a very very unique business
proposition not just business
proposition but a viable business plans
were for the general audience although
it's new but it has many years of
heritage at the essence of it the core
of it is basically about craftsmen and
the years of experience behind it
part of our job being the brand
consultant and the designer is that we
need to see beyond the media itself and
that as a result we came out with a
brand essence of some things worth
sharing the whole objective is to
introduce craft to the general public so
they can actually work on leather it
could be a bag it could be wrapping over
notebooks and so on and so forth we
wanted a space an environment we feel
comfortable coming in and and we wanted
the real craftsmen to be around because
part of my
philosophy was to this put the people
first before anything else so if you
exercise empathy you would know how they
feel and you could probably give him an
environment that they feel comfortable
working in and the biggest challenge for
us to try to get all the senior
craftsmen to face the audience but yet
at the same time it was great because
they they they have they had a heart for
by an artisan so that alone was
comforting than over me but they will
definitely come out the shadow and do
what he's supposed to do
the best piece of advice came from my
nine-year-old daughter she asked me
about the trouble trying to find talent
to fill the positions and she said it's
because they are more interesting
industry out there like the filmmaking
robotics technology I thought my yard
she thinks that way many people would
have the same one of you so it's for me
to continue pushing him so like a
walking advertisement to tell people
educate people what the roles of a
designer is